what would your advice be for people who
are making things in 30 seconds yes
really cherish your enthusiasm we're
really good at teaching people how to be
Duty driven and be diligent about doing
things and I've noticed that for myself
a much better fuel is if I'm genuinely
excited about something and that's when
I really get done but it requires a
lot of taking care of yourself and
making sure that you have the right
parameters so just figure out figure
that out that's rubbish advice not
quotable at all that's Swedish that will
work already what about you I think the
thing is is beginning with failure I
mean count on the fact that you're gonna
fail and that failure is to be accepted
and actually welcomed so the first
things you do second things even the
third things aren't going to work and
that's just perfectly okay and you
should really embrace that
so make stuff that fail yeah all right
you